>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Ruth Tam: Hello, thank you
so much for joining us today,
my name is Ruth Tam, I'm a
producer for The Kojo Nnamdi Show.
It's a talk show on
WAMU, D.C.'s NPR station.
NPR happens to be a media partner
of today's festival, which is hosted
by the Library of Congress.
I want to thank the co-chairman of
today's festival, David Rubenstein
and many of the National
Festival sponsors
who have made today's
event possible.
Today's conversation with Lois Lowry
will be followed by a recorded Q&A.
So before we get started,
I'd like to remind you all
to silence your cell phones.
>> Lois Lowry: Ah, my
cell phone is down there.
>> I just want to [inaudible].
>> Ruth Tam: [Background speaker]
Nearly every year since 1977,
Lois Lowry has published a new book,
but perhaps even more impressive
than the number of books she's
published are the lessons
that we've all gleamed from them.
She doesn't know it,
but when I was 8,
Lois Lowry taught me the
importance of questioning authority
and the value of memory,
in The Giver.
She taught me how to empathize
and be brave and number the stars.
And she gave me a model through her
Anastasia series, for what it means
to be unabashedly yourself.
Most of all, Lois Lowry gave
me a mirror to see my own life,
helping me to better confront my
dreams, my curiosities, my fears.
Now, Lois Lowry turns that
same mirror onto herself
in an update version of
her memoire, Looking Back.
Please join me in welcoming
Lois Lowry.
>> Lois Lowry: Thank you, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ruth Tam: Lois, thank you so
much for being with us today.
In The Giver, The Giver
transmits memories to Jonas
and you wrote your memoire looking
back in kind of a similar way.
You share your life in bursts
of memories with the reader.
I'm wondering, when you wrote the
original version of Looking Back
in the late 90s, just a couple
years after your wrote The Giver.
Was this how you imagined you
wanted to tell your story?
Through a burst of memory?
>> Lois Lowry: I don't
know that it was conscious,
consciously related to The Giver.
But certainly, my life,
like everybody's is made
up of a set of memories.
And when I wrote the first
book, which is shown here,
I did it by trying to
answer the question
that so many people have asked and
still ask of how I get my ideas.
In thinking about that and how
to answer it I realized that many
of my, ideas for books or
many of the things that appear
in my books, come from my own life.
And, in thinking about that I
went back through the boxes,
in my family I became the recipient
of all the family photographs
including all the blurred snapshots
of a cat whose name
you don't remember.
But in looking through
those, I identified moments
that later appeared in books.
And so I put it together in
that way, fragments, it's not,
arranged in any linear fashion.
And so to call it an autobiography
is, a mistake, it isn't really,
it's not, and then I did
this and then I did that.
It's the little pieces that
appeared later in books,
that the book identified
and then a photograph.
My father was a photographer
and so eventually was I,
so I had a great store
of photographs.
This one, of me on the first
cover I'm about 4 years old.
And I'm interested and I like the
fact that the new version, same book
but 20 years added to it,
is the different photograph.
And what fascinates me about
this, is that I'm probably 5 or 6.
But when I look at this photograph,
and this I think is relevant
to why I write for
kids, because I do this.
I look at this photograph,
and I relive that moment,
I remember that moment.
I remember how the sand felt
on my feet, this is in a lake
where we spent summers
in Pennsylvania.
I remember that horrible
bathing suit and I, look at me,
I'm doing this because
it was uncomfortable.
And I also remember the
smell of the, changing place
where we would go into change
our clothes, and it was dank
and had mold and there was always
a daddy long legs on the wall.
And all of that comes back to
me, when I see the photograph.
And throughout the book, which
is comprised of photographs,
each one of those photographs
does that for me,
makes me relive that moment.
As I eventually relived
it by rewriting it often
with a different protagonist
in a book for kids.
>> Ruth Tam: Given the seriousness
of some of your best known works,
it's really great to see how
funny this memoire actually is,
and obviously the cover of the
photo, is a funny, a funny photo.
It's got some humorous
memories behind it.
I'm wondering how did you
balance memories of happiness
in with hardships that have happened
in your life, namely the death
of your sister, your
son, and your partner.
>> Lois Lowry: Well, here's
my sister in this photograph,
with that look on her
face, like she hates
that moment just as much as I did.
And my sister was a very
important person in my life,
and the book begins, or early on
there are a number of pictures,
and this is my only really
autobiographical novel,
which talks about the two sisters.
But, here we are here
there are a number
of pictures of me and my sister.
Everybody's life, if they live
to any age at all, and I'll be 80
on my next birthday, is going
to have episodes of great loss
as well as great happiness.
And that's what makes up our
lives, and so that's what I put
into this book, each
of those moments.
And I talked at length and
used a number of photographs,
this is a photograph
that I have to explain.
Sorry about that.
But it's an example of
what I was just describing,
the dress that my sister is
wearing, in this photograph,
and she's 7 years old, I'm 4.
I coveted desperately, I wanted that
dress so badly, but it was hers.
And the photograph is black and
white, but I remember the color
of that dress and it was the exact
color of the Campbell's tomato soup
that my mother would
give us, often for lunch.
Any rate, here we are
again, the two sisters,
and I think that's
one more picture here.
And here she's teaching me to read.
>> Mic for two second because
you're talking to the other side.
>> Lois Lowry: I can hold it.
That's fine, thank you.
>> Your welcome.
>> Lois Lowry: And so here
I think this shows something
of the importance that my
sister, her role in my life.
And then of course, later in the
book I don't have photographs
of this section of the book.
I talk about the death of my sister.
Same thing, about many years
later, of the death of my son.
All of those things weave together
to create the fabric, of a life.
And if you try to focus
on just the sunny days,
it would be a dishonest
representation.
>> Ruth Tam: Now the
last time that you were
at the National Book
Festival you said
that The Giver was partly
inspired by your aging father.
And when his memory began to fall
through, you were thinking about,
the, how truthful memory
is and how it serves us.
And I'm curious about, how
when you wrote your memoire
and when you updated it recently,
did you ever question things
that happened to you or
reinvestigate your feelings
about things that have
happened in the past?
>> Lois Lowry: Hmm,
complicated question, tough one.
I think, you know as I went through,
too updated to add 20 years,
since the publication,
and find things.
And I included in the
updated section,
the making of the movie The Giver.
I included a number of other
things, grandchildren who hadn't
yet been born during
that first publication.
And so I went back through all those
things, and found those moments
and the things that
related to them in books.
I don't think it involved
any rethinking because to me,
20 years has gone, anybody here
who's my age or around my age,
realizes how quickly time
passes, after a certain age.
And so, for me, 20 years has gone by
in a heartbeat, and it's those days,
19 years ago seem like
yesterday to me.
So to me, they didn't
require reinvestigation
because they happened yesterday.
>> Ruth Tam: One question
I'd like to revisit.
One of the things that you
said you've always liked
about The Giver is that
readers could make up their own,
ending for what happened
to Gab and Jonas.
And you lied.
>> Lois Lowry: I lied, yeah.
>> Ruth Tam: You lied, did
anyone send you a letter
that tells you, you could lie?
>> Lois Lowry: People have
complained about that.
People say I read that
speech you wrote or,
the Newbery Acceptance
Speech for The Giver
and she said you weren't
going to divulge the ending.
At the time I wrote
it, I had no plans
to write any sequels
or follow up books.
But I do respond to, letters
and emails today from readers.
And I do think about their requests,
although I don't always follow their
requests like, you know the kid
who writes and says why don't
you write an adventure book
with a super hero, I'm
not going to do that.
But, after The Giver was published,
and the ending was ambiguous,
purposely so, although I always
thought it was an optimistic ending.
Many, many, many kids wrote and
asked for more books to follow that.
And so, it was some years later
that I wrote the second book,
and then some years after that, the
third, and then finally, the fourth
and final book which draws
all the characters together.
Now I've forgotten
what your question was.
>> Ruth Tam: So I didn't
actually get to it.
>> Lois Lowry: Sorry.
>> Ruth Tam: But I mean I kind
of was wondering why you then
decided to change your mind and.
>> Lois Lowry: Yeah.
>> Ruth Tam: Give the readers
what they're asking for.
>> Lois Lowry: And also I found,
well okay, confession time.
The second book is Gathering Blue.
And that was a book that I
did not sit down to write
as a companion book to The Giver.
It was a book that was new to
me, and a whole separate book.
And I began as I always
do, with a character and I,
always see the character in my mind
and in this case, I
saw a young girl.
They always come, interestingly
with a name,
only once have I changed the
name from what first came to me
and that was with the book Son.
But in this case, a girl named Kira,
she was a particular age, a young,
maybe 14, and I could see
her in a certain situation,
that was the beginning of a book.
And as at began to evolve I saw
it as a time in the distant,
it was a very primitive society and
a, kind of a wilderness village.
And it was only, as I
approached the end of it,
and that was at the same time that
I was still getting so many letters
from kids asking about
the ending of The Giver.
I suddenly thought, I can
connect those two books.
And so at the very end, unnamed
you see that the character Jonas,
from the first book is still alive.
Kids always know who he is,
adults, because he's not named,
sometimes miss that reference.
And so there he was, and,
that book was published.
I don't know what year.
And, then the third book, Messenger,
goes to the village where Jonas is,
and so he's now a character
in the third book.
And he's an adult.
And the little boy from the
second book is the main character,
the adolescent.
I did get some, not complaints but
questions about how could these two,
places in the first two books,
coexist at the same time?
The world of The Giver
is so, futuristic,
and the world of Gathering
Blue is so primitive.
And as I was thinking how to answer
that question and whether perhaps,
I would have to say, okay
guys, it couldn't happen,
but give me a break it's
fiction, right [laughter]?
But at the time, I had a cousin,
I still have the same cousin,
whose daughter works for
the state department.
And at that, and she
goes from place to place.
Let's see, generally 2
years in each embassy.
And at that time, she
was in Pakistan.
So that was happening, my
daughter, my cousin's daughter.
Betsy was working in Pakistan and
she was emailing home every day,
and sending photographs
from Pakistan.
And at the same time, I began
to send money each month
to a wonderful organization called
Women to Women International.
And I was given a woman, and
I had her picture, on my desk,
and she lived in Afghanistan.
In a hut with a dirt floor
and she was trying to raise
and educate 4 children, and she
had no electricity and no plumbing.
And I was paying so her
children could go to school.
And, theoretically, Afghanistan,
Pakistan, you could walk
from one place to another,
it would take you awhile
and it would be hard, but
those two places coexisted.
And so that's how I answered that
question about those two books.
And now I've again forgotten
what you asked, sorry.
This is the way I write a
book incidentally [laughter].
I start writing about something
and then my mind goes over here
and I add to that and that, and
then I forget what I was writing
in the first place.
It generally works, okay.
Got another question?
>> Ruth Tam: [Laughter]
Well it seems like,
obviously from the way you
approach your fiction books
and the way you've written
your memoire that you enjoy,
let's call them non-traditional
narratives and you
like a little bit of ambiguity.
When you write, how much information
do you side, do you decide to leave
in and what, information are
you okay with taking out,
and letting the readers take over?
>> Lois Lowry: Now,
that's a good question.
I always, I bet most authors
would say this if not all.
You always know more
than is in the book.
I'm just thinking of a story
I can tell you that might,
answer this question
in a very graphic way.
My very first book was
called A Summer to Die,
it was published back in 1977.
It's still in print, it's had
different covers through the years.
But, after it was published,
I got a,
letter from a little girl in Denver.
And, she said she had read this
book, and she said she wanted
to be a writer when she grew up,
I think she was 11 years old.
And she was going to
enter a writing contest
at that Denver Post
was holding for kids.
And she said but, I just want
to ask you some questions,
she said that when the, there's a
scene in a meadow, and she said,
I could just see that meadow,
how did you make me
able to see that meadow?
And I wrote back and I said, I could
see it myself, in my imagination.
And I saw it like a photograph
might be of a beautiful meadow,
but I couldn't put every blade of
grass and every leaf on every tree
or every petal on every flower.
I couldn't put all of that in
the book, and so I had to select,
and I had to leave out a lot,
and I tried to select what would
enable you to see the meadow.
I put in just a few details, and you
told me you could see the meadow.
And that's what a writer
does, put in just enough
so the reader can create
their own, place, their own,
character, their own whatever.
So, I got a second letter
from the little girl,
who incidentally had terrible
handwriting [laughter].
And she said, thank you, she
said I see what you mean, I,
now I've read Anastasia Krupnik, in
which the child, the second book,
the child has a baby brother.
And she said there's a scene
where, you're describing,
the hallway in their apartment.
And her little brother
walking down the hall,
and she said I could just see
him, his shoelaces were untied,
and his backside was bulky
because he still wore diapers.
And there was a stain
on the wallpaper,
because you put those details in,
and she said I could see the whole
scene, even though you didn't,
tell me every single thing in it.
And I think it was the second letter
where she said she was
entering the writing contest.
So, then I got the third and
final letter from this child
and it wasn't really a letter it
was a page of the Denver Post,
that she had folded
and put in the envelope
and she had written her terrible
handwriting on it, I did it, I won.
And there is a huge
picture of the child
and I can still see
her face in my memory.
And the caption under the picture
was, blind child wins writing award.
Isn't that an amazing story?
You know if I put that in the
book the editor would say,
credibility issues here.
But I think despite
the fact of this child
who would now be, in
her 40s or 50s even.
Despite the fact of her
particular circumstance,
it does illustrate what, the answer
I'm trying to give to you which is,
you just put in just enough
so that the reader can create
his own world, her own world.
And see it, and it will not
be the world that you saw,
because it's a reciprocal
act, book writing.
You do your thing, and they do their
thing and you each create a book.
>> Ruth Tam: That's
a beautiful story.
I wanted to know, your first
book, you published in 1977,
and in the nearly 4 decades
that have gone by since,
you've published nearly
one book every year.
I'm wondering, when did you
realize you first wanted
to write books specifically
for young people?
>> Lois Lowry: I'm going to
answer that in two parts.
When did I first specifically
know I wanted to be a writer?
If anybody here wanted to do,
boring research you could
find, an archive somewhere.
On an August, 1947 issue
of Jack and Jill magazine,
a magazine that was
published for children then.
And they published
letters from children.
And there were two, I don't
want to call it a center fold,
but the two center pages,
and in the August issue,
1947 there was a letter
from 10 year-old me.
And it said I'm writing a novel.
It was that age at which I already
knew I wanted to be a writer.
Whatever novel I was then
writing, never saw the light of day
and I'm sure it was never finished
but I would have been
working hard at it.
But I saw, I majored in writing
in college then I went
off to Brown at age 17.
But I envisioned being a
writer and that was my goal.
And it's what I majored
in, in college,
but I envisioned writing for adults.
It never occurred to me to write
for kids, though I had been one.
Though I eventually had four of
them, before I was 25, incidentally.
And it was only when, I published
a short story in a magazine,
which was a magazine for adults.
I hesitate to tell you the name of
it, though it still exists, I think.
But it was Redbook magazine, and at
that time, they published fiction.
All of these magazines morphed
into magazines that now,
tell you more than you
want to know about make-up
and clothes, and your sex life.
But at that time, they
published fiction.
I had published a story in
Redbook that was a story for adults
but it was about a child.
It was Seen Through the Eyes of a
Child, and when that was published,
a children's book editor from
Houghton Mifflin read it and wrote
to me and said would you consider
writing a book for young people.
It had never occurred to
me to do that, but that's,
with that invitation, when I
sat down to write what turned
out to be my first
book, A Summer to Die.
Which was a fictionalized
retelling of, the loss of my sister.
I think often, writers writing
a first book will incorporate,
pivotal experiences
in their own lives.
And that's certainly what I did.
>> Ruth Tam: So our time with Lois
Lowry is coming to a close soon
but we're not going to leave
without giving you the chance
to ask your own questions.
So if you have a question
for Lois Lowry,
please head on to the mics
and, we will turn to you.
Let's start over here, with
this, with this, this side.
>> Hi. If you could live in
any of your dystopian novels,
which one would you want to live in?
>> Lois Lowry: If I, when you say
the dystopian novels, you're talking
about the four that form
The Giver Quartet I think.
>> Yes.
>> Lois Lowry: If I could
live in any of those.
You know I didn't get
to the point of talking
about the fourth one, The Son.
But the village, in that one,
by the end of the book,
is where I would live.
Because it has, it's through the,
actions of the various characters,
many of them young, been healed.
And so many of the deep flaws
within those different
civilizations have been changed.
I try always, to end with an
optimistic ending and I think
that one does, so that's
where I would live.
>> Thank you.
>> Ruth Tam: And from here.
>> So, after reading The Giver,
being a science fiction reader,
manger reader, HP Lovecraft,
Douglas Adams.
Did any of your ideas spark from
science fiction, like the type of,
like color coming into play,
only after the reader thinking,
oh there's color and then realizing,
oh, they can only see red now.
So, did any of it come from that?
>> Ruth Tam: Did any of your ideas
come from stories that you saw
on science fiction, were you
influenced by that in any way?
>> Lois Lowry: Hmm,
confession, I am not a reader
of science fiction or fantasy.
I, when I was in college
I had to read,
some of the classic
dystopian novels,
like 1984 and Brave New World.
They were not among my
favorites [laughter].
And, so I never, aspired to
write science fiction or fantasy.
And when I began writing, The
Giver I didn't see it as that.
It was only gradually that, I began
to see it was futuristic, but I,
you know I wrote it like
a contemporary novel.
It doesn't, and I studiously
avoided any science,
so that when kids write me today and
want to know exactly the technology
that allowed them to
do this, this or that,
I tell them I don't have a clue.
You know, make it up.
>> Ruth Tam: Your question.
>> Hi, what kind of
toothpaste do you use?
>> Lois Lowry: What
was the question?
>> Ruth Tam: What kind of
toothpaste do you use, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Lois Lowry: You know my
father was a dentist, don't you?
And I'm curious why you
asked that question.
>> It's like an interesting
thing to know, I guess.
>> Lois Lowry: You know it's
interesting that readers,
and I'm one who feels the
same way about authors.
I'd love to know what kind
of toothpaste Ann McEwan
uses [laughter].
It's you just want to get
a glimpse into the life
of somebody you admire, and so
you focus on those little details,
Crest is the answer [laughter].
And, but I get emails all the time
asking me what kind of food I like,
and what my dog's name is.
And I think it's just
because you want
to be friends with, that author.
And I feel that way about a number
of authors, so I understand that.
>> Ruth Tam: I think we
feel that way about you.
>> What is the book that
you gift to others the most?
Maybe one by, maybe a
book you didn't write.
>> Lois Lowry: I want to make
sure I heard the correctly,
what book do I give
other people the most,
and do you mean one of my own or.
>> Ruth Tam: Another book.
>> Lois Lowry: Or another book.
I'm going to answer that, I'm
going to answer both questions.
One of which is my own question.
The book of mine that
I, most like to give
to people is the book
called Autumn Street,
the one that I mentioned
was autobiographical.
I love that book, I think because
the people in it were people I loved
and most of whom are gone now.
But obviously I don't inflict
that on everybody I know.
And so when I'm called upon now
to give somebody a gift it
depends on what's current.
And I will tell you that, the book
I've given to people most often,
this past year, was a book I'm
trying to think of the title
to get the title accurately.
I think it's When Breath
Becomes Air,
which is a wonderful
title, but Paul Kalanithi.
I don't have time to go
into it, you can look it up.
>> Ruth Tam: Over here.
>> Hi, I just want to say thank you
for your engrossing
novels and characters.
I've been teaching The Giver for
14 years now, the kids always want
to know how does climate
control work,
and is The Giver Jonas' father?
>> Lois Lowry: Thank you, thank you.
Did, I have a little difficulty
hearing these questions.
Was there a question at the end of
that, I'm thanking her for saying.
>> Ruth Tam: Is The Giver Jonas'
father, is that the question?
>> How does climate control work?
>> Lois Lowry: Oh, is
The Giver Jonas' father?
You know, I've been asked that,
often by kids who actually.
And I think the process by
which they, produce children
in that society, means
that you don't know.
It's probably a sperm
bank of some sort.
So my guess would be no.
But whatever you.
>> and how does climate
control work?
>> Lois Lowry: Pardon me.
>> How does climate control work?
>> Lois Lowry: Technology,
look it up [laughter].
>> Thank you.
>> Ruth Tam: We have time
for a couple more questions,
let's take one from here.
>> Hello, oh how do I start?
You are one of my favorite authors
of all time, I have been reading,
my mom introduced me to
your books when I was what?
9/10ish. And we have the collection
of The Giver Quartet at home.
I absolutely adore your books
and every time I read them,
I can see bits of myself,
bits of other people I know,
scattered throughout the book and
connections that I can really make
with things going on
in the real world.
So I wanted to know, how, it's
mostly about the social structure
of the communities you create,
the worlds that you built.
Is there any main inspiration
that came from your life
to inspire these, like social
structures, like the, complete chaos
and disarray of Gathering Blue, the
order and sameness of the Giver.
What inspired that social.
>> Lois Lowry: Okay, I can answer
that, for the part about The Giver.
Of the chaos and disarray
of Gathering Blue,
can from my imagination, I think.
Well I don't think, I know that,
and probably influenced by.
For a long time I've wanted to write
a novel set in the 14th century.
And so I've read a lot of, I
have a whole shelf of books
about Medieval times, and
I've not written that novel.
But, that kind of chaos existed more
so in those times, but The Giver
and the order and structure.
My father was a career army officer,
and I grew up on army posts.
And, I pictured the world,
the community that Jonas lived
in as looking very much like the
army posts, that I grew up in.
Every day, for example, probably
some you here have military
backgrounds, but, every day at 5
o'clock, the, what are they blow
on the bugle at 5 o'clock?
It's not, it's revelry
in the morning,
it's something at 5 o'clock.
And the cannon would go off.
And first the cannon,
and you'd hear the cannon
and everybody would stop
what they were doing.
I remember my little brother
dropping his bike to the ground
and standing solemnly with
his hand over his heart.
And my mother at the clothes line,
stopping, putting the clothes pin
down and standing solemnly.
While we listened to the bugle
call there in the evening.
That seems kind of spooky to me now.
But it's the kind of
the world of The Giver,
where there are these
rules that you follow and,
perhaps they once had a good
reason, for having been created.
And maybe the reason is obsolete,
but that was I think quite clearly,
the inspiration for that
particular kind of community.
>> Ruth Tam: I'm sorry to say
that that's all the time we
have with Lois Lowry today.
The good news is that she's
signing books from 2 to 3 p.m.
on the expo floor on
the lower levels.
>> Lois Lowry: Do I have time
to tell them one funny story?
>> Ruth Tam: Do we have time?
>> Lois Lowry: Very
quickly, very quickly.
Because it's in the book.
And so this is what's your
appetite for the book.
I didn't have time here to
talk about the movie, but,
when I was in Cape Town
watching them film the movie,
they asked me if I wanted
to be one of the elders,
seated in a semi-circle on
the stage at the ceremony.
And I said no.
And I said jokingly to Jeff Bridges,
the one who had asked me that,
I said now if you had left the
scene in with the naked lady
in the bathtub, the old
lady in the bathtub,
I could have played the
lady in the bathtub.
And he laughed and
he knew I was joking.
And then, on the Stephen
Colbert show, he says she wanted
to play the role of the lady
in the bathtub [laughter].
Okay, thank you all.
>> Ruth Tam: It was a joke.
Thank you so much for
being with us, Lois Lowry.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at loc.gov.